l'intelligence artificielle s'implante
rapidement dans tous les secteurs
d'activité et on en est une preuve au
québec une entreprise a réussi à
intégrer les preuves des possibilités de
l'intelligence artificielle dans
l'industrie agroalimentaire intérieur de
joliette est maintenant présente un peu
partout en amérique du nord et elle
espère révolutionner la production
avicole avec nous car une forêt death
présidente communications ventes et
marketing d'intel ya bonjour madame
faudrait un jour alors dit concrètement
l'intelligence artificielle dans la
production agricole quelle forme ça
prend comment vraiment vous pouvez aider
les agriculteurs mais à la base tout ça
commence par la collecte de données donc
à la ferme on a des capteurs
intelligents qui vont être installées à
la ferme qu'ils ont collecté en continu
et en temps réel des données
l'intelligence artificielle intervient
au niveau de l'analyse de ces données
laissent donc nous on va faire une
analyse très approfondie de ces données
là pour essayer d'amener l'information
utile pour le producteur c'est un
système d' aide à la décision en réalité
la production avicole aujourd'hui c'est
parce que c'était il ya vingt ans c'est
beaucoup plus complexe que ça l'était
normes aimant de facteurs à considérer
et puis pour les producteurs ce système
va venir l'aider un
détecter les difficultés ou les
problèmes de performance ou de santé
animale afin que le problème soit trop
grave justement quel soin de donner vous
pouvez récolter concrètement le système
et modulaire donc on peut avoir un
système avec beaucoup de capteurs ou
très peu d exemple on peut avoir un
débat lancé poulet par exemple pour
collecter le poids des oiseaux
poursuivre la croissance on peut avoir
des balances sur les silos poursuivre
l'alimentation la consommation de la
moulée pour aider aussi les meuneries
dans le réapprovisionnement
c'est le système qui vivait dans le fond
à améliorer l'efficacité opérationnelle
être toute la filière pas juste pour les
producteurs
donc si je comprends bien les données
peuvent être utilisés aussi en amont en
aval par les partenaires et fournisseurs
ledit producteur lui-même tout commence
à la ferme donc le producteur et
propriétaire
ces données mais ils peuvent avoir
intérêt à partager ces données avec des
partenaires on l'a vu durant la pandémie
quand un membre de cette filière là
performant où je pose son rôle comme de
vrais lions le vanni clairement ça crée
des problèmes un peu partout donc tout
le monde a intérêt à collaborer ensemble
puis à coopérer quand les producteurs
acceptent de partager ses données
souvent il va avoir une contrepartie je
vais vous donner un exemple simple c'est
le producteur partage ses données sur la
consommation de moules et de ces oiseaux
avec son/sa meunerie samu ne rien en
échange de vos pairs va probablement
pouvoir optimiser ses coûts de
distribution
ces coûts de transport va être en mesure
même de faire des recommandations sur dd
dieppe différente des améliorations au
lait donc le producteur est gagnant et
l'amènera également pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez ciblé particulièrement les
producteurs de volailles est ce qu'il y
avait une raison bien on vient de
joliette c'est curieux beaucoup viennent
de beaucoup c'est une région très très
connue pour sa production avicole
l'entreprise avait déjà des activités on
avait des contrôleurs climatique donc on
se on s'arrêtait à la au contrôle de
l'équipement on a testé en 2016 de
pousser un peu plus loin pour aller
aider les producteurs à contrôler leurs
performances parce que l'équipement
c'est bien mais ce n'était pas ce qui
allait les aider à passer à l'étape
suivante vous êtes déjà très présent en
amérique du nord où près des producteurs
avicoles qu'est ce que vous voulez faire
maintenant est ce que c'est d'aller vers
d'autres types de productions sortir de
l'amérique du nord 6 ou les plans à
court terme pour la croissance la
croissance est vraiment de continuer à
établir nos positions dans l industrie
agricole mais de sortir de prendre de
l'expansion l'entreprise a été
sélectionné tout récemment pour faire
partie du programme et par croissance
qui fait justement à donner aux
entreprises technologiques québécoises
les moyens de leurs ambitions pour aller
à l'international
donc la production agricole y en a
partout dans le monde la consommation
est en croissance donc c'est la
prochaine étape pour nous non est-ce que
vous vous sentez que les producteurs
sont ouverts à l'idée de faire entrer
l'intelligence artificielle dans leur
production ou ça semble plus compliqué
couverture je serai pas que c'est
compliqué je serai 4 7 6 au début
il ya de plus en plus d'ouverture par
quand les gens voient bien que les défis
sont plus grands qu'un vin et que la
recette qu'on appliquait à vin va
continuer à donner les mêmes résultats
qu'on avait donc tout tout les recours
aux technologies de plus en plus
acceptée il ya aussi le fait que durant
la pandémie les gens justement au vu à
quel point tout le monde était
interdépendants les uns des autres donc
tout ce qui sert à créer plus de
confiance à l'intérieur de la filière
avec la transparence des données ça
vient aussi supporter la production
agricole solide et compétitive aussi il
faut pas oublier ça merci beaucoup
madame forest bonne chance dans vos
projets merci pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
[Musique]
oh